we've done a couple stories on this
there is a massive massive drought in
California right now they are saying
scientists are saying that we literally
are a year away from having a full-on
drought so we sent our stacy leska to
the santa barbara reservoir to see
what's going on hey guys let's taste
Alaska pariah news and we're here in
beautiful Santa Barbara where we're
visiting the desalination plant that
might be going back online after nearly
25 year absence to help bring more water
to the city during California's extreme
drought make sure to check out our full
report coming this Sunday for world
water day and go conserve water right
now all right so we're gonna link you
guys to that report there should be an
annotation right around here or it'll be
in the description right below just a
couple other points of information on
this drought and how severe it is so
right now if you take a 10-minute shower
that uses about 10 gallons of water if
you water your lawn for 10 minutes that
uses 700 gallons of water right now the
Santa Barbara reservoir is at 28%
capacity virtually every reservoir we
have in California is at an all-time low
this strikes me as incredibly important
I saw this story and it's like shouldn't
we all we're in California right now so
just out of our own selfish interest
shouldn't we care more about this if
we're actually a year away yeah I've
been asking my landlord to put in a
dishwasher for a really long time
because it saves money and yet he won't
do it so I feel like now is the time to
get him to wait but there's a dishwasher
because when you're doing your dishes by
hand the running water is constantly
wasting great water and I eat a lot yeah
really though shouldn't we be really
concerned about this I mean this seems
this is one of those science things and
I know people freaked out when
scientists sometimes say there might be
climate change or something like that
they said we don't believe in science
but if scientists are saying we got a
real problem with our water situation in
California and we care I hate to sound
like a science than iron
yeah and I'm usually not but if we're in
such a drastic drought and we're gonna
run out of water in a year which is what
they're saying how come we're still
[ __ ] in it we're still [ __ ] in
water clean water every day every person
in California shits in a bucket of clean
[ __ ] water that's the system
we figured out I would list in Las Vegas
we're gonna make skip the water on there
so that for people to drink so people
can [ __ ] in it in Vegas they don't book
and bring the water and for drinking
it's for pissing and [ __ ] in
perfectly clean water this is our system
we have been come up with another system
when we stop [ __ ] in perfectly clean
water that's what I believe we're in a
real drought you ever costs more than a
dying a gallon coming out of Mike foster
because right now it doesn't cost Oh
maybe even two cents a gallon doesn't
quite anything so maybe if it was more
expensive people would stop [ __ ]
hosing down their driveways my
brother-in-law hoses down a [ __ ]
driveway you know why cause it costs two
cents a gallon right I don't we wanted
to cost two dollars a gallon and people
will start conserving it you know what's
amazing about you you smoke more weed
than anyone I know and you're also the
angriest so to that point so if this
desalination plant that they have in
Santa Barbara if this goes up yeah the
prices of water so you take the salt out
of nothing and I point about us still
[ __ ] in clean water goes right the
boys how to get back to that so the
price of water is gonna go up so maybe
then people will start you know doing
more drought resistant lawns and things
like that but the [ __ ] in the water
so what do you want us to do you want us
to use recycled water I don't know why I
mean I don't know what we we should be
using recycled water why doesn't it just
go to I me not to come to your house
what is it well don't drink the iced tea
but why but why doesn't it go into a
hole in my backyard I just me and my
wife [ __ ] in our house there's gonna
be a hole it can go because there's a
sanitation issue with that
yeah but I'm I'm saying we live in a
first punish its outside and why somehow
it gets taken care of in the backyard
why can't I take care
no I mean equip a check the soil it's
cold well you just leave your dogs
no but if I walk in my pick it up but
when he sits in the back here squirrels
[ __ ] in my backyard I don't pick it up
the raccoons [ __ ] in the backyard I
don't pick it up what was that we were
doing right so it's just a sense that
you would take all the waste human waste
mix it with perfectly clean walk ballons
and gallon
clean water every time I go to the
bathroom it doesn't make any sense yeah
so he's part of the try to get us back
on topic here so yeah go somewhere I was
dating a guy who was from the Central
Valley went out to go visit his family
did a jog around a reservoir and it had
a fair amount of water in it and then
towards the end of a relationship about
a year later I went back and there was
virtually no water and when you see
something like that you recognize where
the difference is when there's a
reservoir that's actually drying up over
the course of a year as my relationship
is drying it was a beautiful metaphor it
cost more money why won't it supply and
demand why doesn't it I mean if they
want us to conserve make it cost more
well I think what's happening is that at
least in California is that the
politicians that are running the state
legislature up in Sacramento they know
that people refuse to pay more and it's
the way politics always work they're
always living for the day they're not
living for what's gonna happen next I
think also part of the problem here is
that when we look at the globe or if you
look at a map it's something like 71% of
the earth is covered by water so people
can't really understand why it's autumn
all right but but I think do you think
that's part of it just visually you look
at a you look at the earth it's blue
because of water so people can't really
understand their mouth I do wonder about
those plants where they can take the
salt out of the water I mean yeah I
don't know what the science is behind
that in it they work I mean they have
them in the Middle East in it and it
works but it takes a tremendous amount
of energy to do oh there you go that's
the problem then energy cost yeah yeah
they're gonna figure out how to get
water out of the seawater and they're
gonna figure out how to cool the thing
so it's all gonna have a spirit talking
they're gonna figure out how to do it
and the science yeah well we really
brought that home with science that's
what I'm talking about people anyway
what do you think are we really a year
away from a massive drought in
California it seems to be happening let
us know what you think in the comments
right